hey guys it is Tuesday the 11th of
October my name is Jeff and here's the
things that mattered in gaming today the
sub Red Dead Revolver has been
re-released on PlayStation 4 you can
grab the game for 15 bucks through the
PlayStation Store starting now it comes
with full 1080p up rendered visuals and
support for trophies share play remote
play and all those other ps4 goodies the
precursor to Red Dead Redemption
initially arrived on ps2 and Xbox in
2004 unfortunately you can't play Red
Dead Redemption on ps4 but it is one of
the titles with backwards compatibility
support on Xbox one is a wall for
developer the Coalition has released an
update for the game making it easier for
you to get your hands on credit the
currency which is used to purchase
booster cards that can increase your
skills and performance will now cost a
lot less the elite pack credit is now
3,500 as opposed to 4,000 and match
completion bonus credits in versus
multiplayer have been increased the
Coalition explained this should provide
a higher and more consistent credit earn
rate across our modes with the leveling
milestone drops of 500 credits and
credit bounties also helping you on your
road to your next pack the developer
added that they are aware of a bug that
will display no credit earning from a
match bonus and that is not reflected in
your credit wallet where you should see
an increase finally overwatch Halloween
loot boxes are indeed a thing that's
happening and then our live across all
platforms
I've watch's Halloween update includes a
loot boxes that provide new skins
victory poses and moats voice lines and
plenty of other things that are all
delightfully Halloween themed
interestingly this time around you can
purchase these items with in-game
currency which you were unable to do
during the summer games event you can
pick up a free loop box just for logging
in so that's a thing you'll probably
want to do the update has also added a
co-op brawl mode pratima for defense the
irken vault castle gates from waves of
computer-controlled enemies
active if you want to see some of the
new items check out our story on site
did leave me lots on today stories in
that comment box and head to GameSpot
where we've got news on battlefield one
and GTA 5 I will see you again tomorrow